bring in Tanya Hajj Hassan now who's a
pediatric intensive care doctor and
works with Doctors Without Borders she's
also co-founder of Gaza medic voices she
joins us from Aman uh Tanya haassan a
warm welcome to you firstly your
response from what you are hearing
tonight coming out of Northern Gaza
particularly in and around the shiffer
hospital I mean it's horrific the direct
targeting started last night obviously
this is not the the first time this week
but uh quite heavily overnight last
night they hit the entrance of elifa
Hospital the emergency uh Department
entrance as well as the backside of
elifa hospital they also hit the labor
and delivery Ward directly so one of our
colleagues sent us uh footage of smoke
coming from the top of the hospital I'm
sure I haven't had a chance to watch uh
the news the footage that you've shared
on Al jazer today but I'm sure you've
shared uh the the entrance of the
hospital and the the compound that was
hit and the the the massacre of
internally displaced people there were
at least 13 people killed there were uh
there was blood everywhere there were
there were uh refugees on the floor uh
uh complete leg amputation from from the
explosion hemorrhaging onto the ground
children that were dead lying on the
ground I mean really horrific horrific
images of a hos Hospital
compound and ever since then I mean we
we've received repeated reports uh
colleagues working for msf have sent
testimonies in of the hospital being
bombarded of them trying to figure out
uh how to find safety colleagues in and
out of chifa are are are begging for for
international intervention we received
this message from the director of
surgery at El shifa he said dear
colleagues the situation in shifa now is
extremely dangerous we as medical staff
want to leave but we cannot we might not
survive till morning we don't want to be
killed here not only because we remained
committed to our patients or just only
because we remain committed to our
patients and our medical profession I am
calling for help urgently please do
whatever you can through your government
or through the the International Red
Cross to arrange a safe Corridor for
medical staff please treat this as top
urgent I'm go ahead this is the fourth
Hospital the fourth or fifth Hospital in
the last 24 hours that has been targeted
I I am I am speechless this is
prohibited under international law it
is it is known that targeting a
functional hospital is is is a war crime
our colleagues are are are in there
treating patients I I I I have no more
words every
humanitarian provider every humanitarian
doctor every organization has been out
there for weeks saying this has got to
stop and every day there's a new level
of atrocious ruthless impunity with
which these crimes are being committed
they are crimes against humanity I am
pleading with Leaders with with with
with individuals with organizations
whoever you are if you're listening to
this you you I I I I can't imagine your
Humanity saying anything other than this
has to stop Tanya do do do stay with us
I'm just going to remind our viewers of
what they are seeing on their television
screens at the moment but because we've
heard now of this Israeli bombardment
that has hit the shiffer hospital that
is the largest medical facility in the
Gaza Strip it's been regarded for a long
time now as a safe haven for people uh
trying to escape and avoid the conflict
uh Dr Tanya Hajj Hassan you know that
hospital well you can only we can only
imagine the strain and the pressure that
doctors there are under and now this
bombardment where could possibly the
people who are in that hospital many of
them injured many already in need of
dire D support where could they get to
where could they escape
to I don't know I mean all the
international organizations have been
saying for weeks it is impossible to
evacuate that patient that that hospital
with without giving a death sentence to
these patients there are intensive care
patients on ventilators you cannot
transport these patients one of my
colleagues the surgeon described
evacuating this morning on a donkey cart
and on foot with snipers and tanks
pointing at her and and and crude things
being yelled at her by the by the
Israeli soldiers I I I am am am just
speechless
I and I'm sorry if you hear the anger
frustration desperation sadness in my
voice all of those things are true I I
am genuinely fearful of the level of
impunity which which which which with
this is happening these
are
unprecedented H crimes against humanity
in modern times we know
better